one of the things that Freud did when he
was interpreting dreams and it's quite
useful you know so if someone comes to
me with a dream then I have them tell me
the whole dream and then I get them to
repeat it line by line and then whenever
they say a line and it there's an object
in it or a person or something like that
I asked them what that makes them
remember or what that thing means to
them or what comes to mind and that's
the associational technique and it's
predicated on the idea that your memory
works by association and you know that
if you're daydreaming you know you go
from one thing to another like a
conversation does and that you can take
an idea that's at the center of a web of
associations and by tracking the
associations you can kind of zero in on
what the idea might mean and then you
expanded that by trying to he called it
to amplify the dream by thinking about
about narrative or literary or
mythological similarities that that
might be associated with the narrative
structure of the dream and and I think
often that can be unbelievably useful
you know and it's like the dream is an
idea that's trying to come to birth it's
partly formulated and then if you
discuss it and amplify it it's like you
can speed along its transformation into
a more articulated idea and the dream is
also something that because your brain
your mind is trying to with one foot in
the unknown it's trying to formulate
what's out there in the unknown and to
make it concrete but but it doesn't do
that in one fell swoop it doesn't just
take potential and turn it into two
articulated ideas it has to dream up
what's out there first projects its
imagination out there to get a handle on
what it might be it then that's
presented in the dream and if you
analyze the dream you can make it more
articulate